Oh give me some more I have no idea the
actual words that song
but either way last week I made eggs and
asked you guys what you wanted me to
make this week there was an overwhelming
response for pizza so I did what an
enormous who wants to make pizza does I
bought some Tomatoes bought some pizza
dough in a big pan and I'm going to put
all of these things into it and cook it
as always leave me a comment of what
you'd like me to make next all right so
first steps first I've got my tomatoes
I've got a whole bowl full of them and
we're gonna blend them up obviously to
make our sauce and the next thing is I'm
just gonna juggle these tomatoes because
I can juggle no definitely missed the
point of this is it's time to make this
sauce one tomato two Tomatoes three
tomatoes
we need more mom a doze should you put
all of them in here this doesn't look
like tomato sauce here we go again
is it because I use organic tomatoes
this isn't very red that's a lot of
sauce step two we need to make the pizza
crust but don't you worry
Whole Foods made it for me place on
floured surface and flatten to desired
thickness without rolling pin the guy
Whole Foods told me that I could in fact
cook a pizza in here the picture that
was on the flyer inside of here was a
chicken to feel like this is what you
would roast a turkey or something min
not that I ever ever will do that in my
lifetime next I'm going to take my dough
and put it in the pan
okay sauce you look great but you gotta
move it's almost like I made it for real
like a little baby's bottom
this is how my butt feels there's not a
single muscle in my butt mmm that's got
to change
feel like maybe like do all kinds of
flips and stuff stretch stretch is this
even doing anything I'm sure your mom
stretch it and see what happens Pizza
Hut's gonna be calling and be like we
need your services ASAP
[Music]
I think this is doing something guys
this is actually working if you spin
around in circles and pull the pizza
cross gravity gravity I'm so dizzy right
now I can't even stand up okay I use it
down there's no time to be dizzy because
I have to flatten this pizza crust out
okay Papa John's let me tell you a
little thing or two about making pizza
ah you can just call me mama John's
definitely should have taken us out of
the fridge first whatever we're done
here we're done here this is what we've
got pizza is in the pan it's like this
is the only cheese that I have it's
pepper jack i like pepper jack
we're going to pour the sauce to the
pizza hmm let's just we're just gonna
fill it all up it's gonna be like a
little zon you know okay so somewhere
inside of here is my pizza
okay we've got our cheese I'm going to
this is so much fun and no look at this
we do it this way busy with this body
houses right
I was so successful like cooking its
cheetah's heavy I just get a little
smaller piece I think I've lost track of
where the bread actually is guys I got
him to work out for it what's called
grating cheese cheese is like melting in
my hand yeah oh my self I'm sick of
grating cheese so I'm just gonna put
this put you there put you there looks
delicious let's put it in the other ten
to 12 minutes best if cooked on
preheated pizza stone pipe create a
pizza stone and what is a preheated
pizza stone I don't know I mean you
can't have a pizza without any kind of
suffice is the amount of me
pepper hope you like pepper whoever is
gonna taste this me it's Celtic sea salt
so you know it's gonna be delicious
let's try some garlic salt garlic and
pizza is like real good ain't about that
measuring life nope
oh ho that looks like soup
there she goes okay oh the time is now
oh my goodness what's happening in there
don't know what's happening here I don't
think you're done somebody lied to me
okay we're in try again I think I need
to pick it up because I'm starting to
smell some burning now no camera almost
fell into the pizza I think the problem
is because it is it's swimming in sauce
that's definitely the problem so I think
what I have to do is dump some of the
sauce out I gotta get this Pizza onto
this pan what if I slip it under here
there's too much sauce it's not allowing
it to be the pizza that it has to be
[Music]
this is all cheese just chew on top of
here to let you just think about what
you've done how can one person be so
stupid I can't actually put this into
the oven because it's going to destroy
it I'm just trying to make it into a
circle at this point is it a cake is it
a pizza this is something that I thought
was gonna be simple
what does it like to be normal
alright at this point if this doesn't
work we're just gonna have to say screw
it well friends thanks for watching if
you'd like to see the taste test of said
pizza check this video here on my second
channel make sure you guys subscribe
I'll see you soon I'm gonna go eat this
[Music]
can't even call it a pizza I can't call
this pizza